a major new development in the fight
against covid we are one step closer to
a coveted vaccine for kids under six
years old moderna is asking the fda for
a so-called emergency use authorization
for their two-dose covet-19 vaccine it
would be available for kids as young as
six months of age and up to six years of
age coveted cases among kids under 17 in
general on the rise up 43 percent from
just two weeks ago we spoke to one
mother from iowa who drove across state
lines to enroll her kids in modernist
vaccine trial and they were under five
at the time
as parents
i mean
why would we want to leave them
unprotected from i mean coven i mean the
virus and that can cause long-term
health effect i mean after all it's our
job as parents to teach them and to
protect them
cbs news medical contributor dr david
agust joins us now for more on all this
dr aegis good morning to you a lot of
parents are very anxious and excited to
get this
vaccine for their younger children how
soon could it be available and how
effective might it be
so tony this is a vaccine 28 days apart
two shots about a quarter of the dose
that we see in adults and what it did
was it protected from symptomatic
infection anywhere from kind of mid 30s
to high 40s or 50 percent
in these children um what we know about
these vaccines though is that what
they're really good at is protecting
against serious illness and the immune
studies that is the antibodies seen in
the study were similar to older kids and
so we think that there will be that
protection it's being submitted to the
fda now they've committed to convening
an advisory group in the next several
weeks so i really think by the end of
the month next month we could have this
vaccine out for young kids and at the
same time pfizer soon will submit their
three-shot vaccine data
so dr agus what's interesting we heard
from a mother there from iowa who's very
excited for her kids to get the vaccine
but about two-thirds of parents who can
vaccinate vaccinate their middle-aged
kids six to 12 have not yet suggesting
some hesitancy what would you say to
that group and then also parents of even
younger kids about why this is necessary
in your view
so in february the cdc came out with
data that 75 percent of kids in the
united states has been exposed to covet
already so first of all it means 25
percent haven't but even if you've been
exposed to covid as a child or your
child has they are susceptible to the
new variants and what we know is is that
there are hundreds of hospitalizations
over the last several months in these
kids and long covey can happen as
significantly more children so i am a
believer that you need to get the
vaccine to get enough immunity to
protect yourself against these
especially as the virus continues to
change we're seeing new variants pop up
now we have va.2.1.2.12.1
all of these new variants are are
certainly more infectious and causing
problems so protect the children please
give them the ability so they're not
going to get seriously ill or have long
coven
you said high 30s to 50 efficacy
doesn't seem very high though david
yeah so you know initially we got kind
of low with the original vaccines it was
in the 90s to prevent symptomatic
infection and then the virus started to
change and those numbers went down
but
with the immune bridging studies that is
the antibody studies i do think we're
going to get pretty significant
protection or complete protection
against serious disease and that's what
really matters if your child gets mildly
ill for a couple of days not a big deal
if they get serious covet or long covet
big deal and so i think the vaccines
will do excellent in terms of protecting
against that
david before you go let me ask you about
what something something that dr fauci
recently said he said that the u.s is
out of the pandemic phase then he seemed
to sort of clarify that statement saying
we're more in a controlled phase but the
pandemic isn't over so in your
professional opinion where are we in
this pandemic or
are we still in a pandemic
my professional opinion it sounds kind
of scary very important what i do
believe i do believe is we are now in a
position where we can live with with the
virus rather than hide from it we have
pacs of it a treatment for people who
have serious medical issues a good
portion of the country is vaccinated or
been exposed to covet so with enough
immunity
even in areas of the country now we're
seeing increase in numbers of cases
which there are many
they're not increasing hospitalizations
and deaths so we are learning to live
with the virus because of all the hard
work that america has put in and because
what if science has come through this is
a new phase in the pandemic
you know a lot of big events coming dr
fashion said the other day he's not
going to attend the uh big white house
press correspondents dinner he said
clearly for it's
his own level of comfortability is how
he phrased it so for people who are
going to these big events and there are
a lot coming up what's your take on that
given again we have talked about this
you and i many many times because you
know i'm a very nervous
and i love you for that it is your level
of personal risk and so there is going
to be some risk to going to these events
but again gail you are vaccinated you
are boosted and if you do get infected
we do have packs of it as a drop
backdrop and it clearly works and so
with that we can live with the virus it
is a new era
okay i wasn't asking for me i was asking
for a friend
and i am double boosted david again
david's like i'll see you there yeah
i'll see you there
thank you david it is a new era dr david
agust thank you very much